and saw the metal gear solid 5 phantom
pain but it's not a joke long time long
yeah oh yeah but I didn't all right I
didn't quite bored that one little here
ripe so you guys all had gripes with
this on me here oh no I nah she's meant
to be finish where we all tickets afraid
yeah because the trailer has obviously
been on the internet for some time as
they know it I believe I heard you say
that he doesn't know how to make a
trailer that wasn't me that was actually
tire yeah yeah a to that point yes this
is not your typical game trailer they're
sort of flashing these unrelated scenes
the thing is is that this series has a
trail of characters and family lines
that you know that surpassed decades and
numerous games and so so much of what
these contain are hints as to what will
happen and you can kind of try to infer
based on what you already know so yeah
it is kind of actually like fanservice
quite a bit yeah what did you did you
infer anything from this it's so
freaking hard I mean there's a because
you never know kojima is so good at your
situation yeah yeah exactly and this is
this is a series that involves clones I
mean yeah when you have clones like how
do you ever know if you're looking at
someone that is not a copy of someone
else even from generations back I'm not
entirely convinced that there is only
one big boss there hmm and that's that
kind of changes the whole spectrum of
the story look at that guy that Hitler
my favorite yeah here we are ya Peter's
talking about these epic story plot
we're like look that dummy fun visualize
it is that big shower is what of jurors
from grand zeros that's mother base okay
trying to rebuild by the base oh yeah
which is sort of that they're there
offset it's very reminiscent a big fella
honestly so metal gear solid 5 phantom
pain we were speculating that we might
see some gameplay here but no gameplay
it didn't happen I'm kind of surprised
by that actually because they did show
some during that podcast last week but
there's a good chance they might be
showing stuff on the show floor we'll
see girls hope we have at least on let
you know sometimes they a lot of
admirers are sticking them up on their
YouTube channels after the press
conference who knows yeah